i've been having a tough time with um
the sonic commercial is that the only
place that we are eating now is that it
every commercial i see is just sonic
it's like hey is that the best we can do
as a family that was to
sit together in a car somewhere
there's some kid he's like he's 11
genders he's got that coin thing on his
belt or her belt or on his neck
he's on suicide watch he's on a uh
a ransom list he's an orphan he's a
he's a burn victim you have it's always
somebody that works there they have
every impedament you could have
you know the guy been hit by a car he's
been hit by a truck
you know it's like uh it's definitely
somebody that god is looking for okay
that's who is the employee
and they used to roller skate out to you
you know kind of cute
a little scary when the girl coming out
of roller skates is pregnant that's the
spooky one you're like okay
we just wanted a couple blizzards we
don't want no zygote but
i hope henrietta don't trip on one of
these cracks in the pavement
you know we'll just you know god forbid
you know she lose her child because we
wanted a damn mcflazzle
and then the family or family sitting in
there dad's in the front i mean
i just wonder what is this like for kids
now
at least when i was a kid we went to the
pizza hut
we went in there my dad got a beer or
pulled one out of his pocket that he
brought in there
and asked for a cold glass
my mom sat
kinda near my dad i don't think she
cared about him but i do think
she wanted pizza
i really do and we would sit in there
they would give us some quarters my dad
always had quarters
you know it was all he was older they
had quarters they used to have quarters
and he would get a couple out give them
to us we go play the video games
we lose sometimes we [ __ ] up we put yeah
it takes three quarters you put in one
you're [ __ ] you thick you know you
didn't read the direction you're just
hitting the button nothing happens
you tell the guy there he doesn't know
he makes pizza you tell the delivery
guy's going on you're like the quarter
he's like uh
i'm i'm you know i'm high i just got
robbed you're like well
we're getting robbed everybody's
getting robbed
and then we played a game then when we'd
have anymore we would look under the
machines we would
my one of us would we would use all of
our little baby strength to
lift the machine up somebody reach under
there
pull out half a hamster full of havs to
pull out half a hamster of hair
four barrettes
you know and and maybe uh maybe a
quarter
maybe a quarter comes out with it
then we get the pizza the deep dish
pizza hut used to have the best pizza
pizza hut is a crust of its former self
now they're shooting the [ __ ] crust
of the crust up with cheese it's like uh
you know it's like that bob baffert
scandal you know you don't know what
they're injecting into this [ __ ] to get
you to believe in it
i remember when the crust stood on its
own
you know when is a real italian gonna
make a pizza place
that has some freaking zagoon huh
when you're gonna put some real gonads
on the [ __ ] pie
so we can enjoy it again this [ __ ] out
here domino it's just a flavor it's not
even a thing
it's not even it's barely pizza
and sonic you're sitting dad's in the
front it's like the best we can do as a
family is dry
sit in the car you got the kid in the
back
he has probably asthma and autism
and asthmatism he [ __ ] can't breathe
or know what's going on if there's loud
noises
it just you know dad's up there spilling
chili on himself
mom's over there huffing birth control
you know it just i just don't know
it used to be at least on the
commercials they were
around a dinner table
now it's like hey drive over here
you know park here by the freaking busy
road
oh smell the exhaust while little
lawrence in the back seat chokes on his
damn grilled cheese
i don't know maybe i'm salty about i
don't know why i'm salty but i like it
i like it it takes forever though at
least there used to be the roller
skating girl
you know you see a couple young tits
come out on some wheels
you know make you touch your [ __ ]
crotch for a second
but now you know who knows what it is
now it's just damn you know
it's some kid he comes to the way he
tells you he's an orphan
he's like you know i'm an orphan i'm
like do you have the burgers
okay we're not here
for anything but the burgers
do you have the burgers
do you have the burgers
[Music]
hey do you have the
burgers
he's like i used to be in a wheelchair
you're like do you have a guy
i can't live downstairs anymore baby
because you know where i am
amen baby praise god rat king
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one